recently two tic toc videos by medical
professionals have gone viral and not
for good reasons are these truly mocking
patients or are they just innocent jokes
let's see for ourselves being on social
media as a public figure is hard enough
on its own but being a medical
professional and social media is even
harder look I'm a board-certified family
medicine physician I've been doing
social media for five plus years over
nine million subscribers over four
hundred million views on this YouTube
channel and I'm still figuring it out
so I'm not surprised that medical
professionals who are just getting into
social media are already making some
mistakes and taking some heat for it
what I thought we'd do today is watch
the two videos that have garnered a lot
of negative buzz discuss my thoughts on
those videos and what should happen
moving forward and then leave you off
with some tips that I believe would help
anyone but especially medical
professionals navigate this tricky
social media landscape let's check the
first one out that made national
headlines the tweet that this came from
actually says we know when you're faking
with a few laughing emojis this is
frustrating I'm all about being able to
laugh at ourselves about finding humor
in dark places I've said time and time
again I try and lighten my patients mood
by making jokes quite often even
patients who are the most sick and to be
honest they usually appreciate it
however this is a strong however when I
walk into a patient's room I don't just
blindly make a joke
I first develop a rapport with the
patient understand where they're coming
from pick up their verbal and nonverbal
cues then I say the joke and then I pick
up those cues again to see how the joke
landed it doesn't always land but at
that point I can readjust or explain
when you post a video like this to
social media where millions of people
can
see it now you've lost the ability to
pick up on context the ability to
explain yourself to everyone watching it
what you really meant there's such a
fine line of humor in medicine that you
really just need to be careful
especially in this day and age where
there's a growing distrust of medical
professionals by the general public in
fact there was a huge segment on this
with John Oliver covering medical bias
and it really explored how women and
specifically women of color are actually
this believed disproportionately when it
comes to their symptoms and then a video
like this comes out it Stokes that fire
right away there's just a way to do
tasteful comedy and this was just a Miss
for me let's take a look at the second
video which I found through Twitter but
it was initially posted to tik-tok by
the username mercy medical I usually
like to blur the account names in
people's faces but this video has been
viewed millions of times and I think the
facial expressions actually contribute
to the feel of the video so let's just
take a look at it together
I can definitely see how from one
perspective if you're watching this as
someone who's maybe had symptoms that
have been written off by medical
professionals how that can trigger you
easily if I went to an ER and was saying
I think I have symptoms of a heart
attack as I looked it up online and a
doctor rolls their eyes and says is the
cocaine I would be pretty upset by that
yes patients get their illnesses wrong
they're not doctors yes they're gonna
recite to you something very read online
that's gonna be inaccurate but they're
not doctors now if this person was a
comedian doing this I don't think anyone
would actually be mad but when you're
the person who's supposed to be taking
care of people when they're in the most
insecure moments when they're the most
frightened and you're poking fun or that
situation there's a line there that gets
crossed this video actually came on my
radar from a post by Sarah Mosher odd
that reads as such a post like this
jeopardized the public's trust in
medical professionals why symptoms
aren't taken seriously
she's profiled a person based on age
patient may have googled symptoms to
avoid trip to the ER don't make fun of
patients it is and always will be
unprofessional I actually spoke with
Sarah Moser odd right before making this
video to discuss this feed that really
blew up I think this video has something
like seven million views now and there's
over a thousand comments nearly a
hundred thousand retweets and we
discussed what has come of the
conversation so far what many doctors
initially said when seeing this video
was that no doctor should be on tik-tok
and probably not on social media
altogether but what Sarah told me was
that upon hearing all of this critique
of doctors being on tick-tock she
started coming across examples of
doctors doing a great job educating on
tick tock and other social media
platforms in fact a lot of the people
she told me our names I've either met in
person come across on YouTube or other
platforms that
truly do evidence-based educational and
even fun content I'm actually gonna drop
all their handles in the description box
so you two can check them out I'm not
the only doctor on social media making
videos and in general I want more
doctors on social media not all of them
we don't all need to be there but
certainly there's a lack of quality
evidence-based physicians on there
because misinformation is thriving in
fact social media has become a
misinformation superhighway where
someone makes a thread titled carrots
cure cancer it goes viral because of the
algorithms and now there's no counter
information to it but if we have enough
doctors that have a good reach engaged
viewership they can now put out counter
information to educate patients is this
carrot article true is it true that you
can detoxify your body we can make a
difference there's over three billion
people logged in online across the world
we have to as doctors go to where our
patients are and right now they're on
their phones iPads laptops computers and
their own social media so we need to log
on figure out how to reach them figure
out how to get these algorithms to share
our content and do the best thing we
know how educate and practice preventive
care since I want more medical
professionals online I thought that
within this video I can give five tips
that anyone who is in the medical field
that wants to start a medical account
should take into serious consideration I
in fact made this list when I was doing
my presentation for the Mayo Clinic on
social media so I hope you enjoy it
all right let's kick it off rule number
one if you post it assume everyone will
see it
this means your co-workers hospital
staff patients family members of
patients all of the above and not only
will they see it it will never be
permanently deleted I just came across a
website that actively stores all
instagrams stories that like profile
accounts with more than 5,000 followers
forever just think about that for a
second you could post something change
your mind five seconds later thinking no
one saw it but it forever lives in that
database there was a recent case of a
first-year doctor
also got in trouble on Twitter by making
a post on I believe Instagram where he
sort of put a picture of him looking
quite sultry with the caption saying
ready for your well woman exam and for
those of you who don't know a well woman
exam is a breast and gynecological exam
again I want to be charitable thinking
and thinking that this is not done with
ill intent but it's just like it's poor
taste too
we need to stop the fear-mongering of
professionals being on social media yes
it's hard yes it's not the same as
having a personal account but it is
doable we can learn how to do it we can
learn how to get better at it and it
takes some communication communication
is something that doctors are
traditionally very poor at in fact Sarah
Mozart who I mentioned earlier teaches
science communication and social media
education for the USC medical curriculum
and I applaud her for it she told me
about the way that she discusses certain
case studies how doctors should function
on Yelp there's a lot to be learned here
and unless we discuss it openly like
we're doing now and not just scare
people and say social media is all bad
we're never gonna get better social
media is not going anywhere people love
it they spend hours a day on it so we
need to figure out how to get better at
it instead of just saying oh not for us
I get countless emails weekly of
patients saying because of my videos
they've been vaccinated their children
have been vaccinated they've changed
their stance on cancer screenings they
stopped following crash diets and that's
what this whole journey is about we need
to not down talk social media we need to
figure out what the good parts are the
bad parts are and then make the best
educated decision 3 never give
individualized advice through social
media perform any kind of patient care
or break patient privacy
I mean HIPPA I've seen doctors actually
cross this line about giving patients
direct advice and I don't think that's
ever ideal without doing a proper
history physical and even running some
tests you're going to be doing a
disservice by giving individual advice
to the web for if you're doing any kind
of sponsorship declare it right
way and make sure you're not selling out
to pseudoscience one of my biggest
motivating factors in going on social
media and making these youtube videos
was to debunk pseudoscience to tell
patients that detox teas are a scam
video link below to talk about why
taking the majority of supplements is it
necessary video link down below to talk
about why vaccinations are necessary and
don't cause autism video link down below
and when it comes to sponsorships I do
them there's nothing wrong about being
successful financially on social media
as a doctor just if you're gonna do them
make sure that you let people know right
away that it's a sponsored piece of
content explain why you're doing it and
please before you get into any kind of
arrangement check with your conscience
and your moral compass first to make
sure that you're not deceiving any of
your patients or loyal viewers and
finally number five be humble and ready
to accept critique none of us are
perfect and just because we had a
medical education does not make us
better than anybody we make mistakes I
have well over 200 videos on my channel
and there's some mistakes in them I
always make sure to after the fact
either plug it into the video with a
correction or at least in the
description box that I made a mistake
but we have to be open and admit those
mistakes in fact medical information
changes it changes quite rapidly we
learn new things so you have to make
updates on information that is now
outdated please do not confuse your
Google search with my medical degree
while this is funny it's not exactly
accurate because your medical degree was
earned years ago google has a lot of
up-to-date information on it so you can
be wrong when you approach medical
education with that level of humility
not only do your patients and viewers
get better information but also you get
better because you open up yourself to
critique and debate so it forces you to
learn more be more up-to-date and
essentially be a better medical
professional I put together a playlist
for you of my medical journey you could
check it out right here or if you want
some really interesting medical videos
there's a playlist right here
I'll watch either one of these with you
being happy and healthy
[Music]